I know you met earlier on with Treasury
secretary Jack Lew I know you discussed
Greece did you discuss anything else did
you discuss the currency wars and
possible effects components no no we did
not secretary wants to be informed on
the progress we're making on Greece and
luckily I could give him a positive
message a lot of work has been done
since we reached a political agreement
on the third program for Greece the
Greeks have worked very hard pushing
through structural reforms on all
different fronts and now we're entering
into a debate which is about their depth
sustainability secretary Lew of course
has been urging Europe to provide a debt
relief to Greece mr. diesel bloom are
you concerned that if we don't get debt
relief and if we don't have a solution
for Greece in the next couple of weeks
or months we may look at another summer
of uncertainty on grease on grexit and
on the EU like we did last year no I'm
not worried about that we're in a
completely different situation than we
were a year ago the current Greek
government is very constructive very
constructively working with the European
partners to improve the state of the
economy to improve public services and
administration in Greece and they are
fully committed to the program which is
a completely different situation from
where we were a year ago and on the
basis of that confidence we're now
entering into a discussion about a debt
relief if you look at depth
sustainability of course Greece has a
high sovereign depth we have given them
a very long time to deal with that on
average 32 years and already the
interest is very low but we stand ready
and are now discussing to do more are
you worried or is a key concern for a
lot of g7 finance chief currency wars I
knew you had brought them up in Shanghai
you said what Japan was doing at the
time was a topic of concern will you
raise the same concerns this time
well I think there is general agreement
that adjusting your currency rates just
for the purpose of improving your
competitiveness is not going to work it
only has a short-term effect it will
probably provoke the same kind of
reaction from other currency areas and
the effect will only be short-lived so
the thing to do if you want to improve
competitiveness is to deal with the
structural business environment in your
countries make sure that investments go
up make sure that productivity improves
that's the kind of thing you need to do
if you have a competitiveness problem
and not try and adjust your currency
rate mr. Jessel bloom Tom Keenan er good
morning do you thank you for joining us
from Japan if i look at the dance over
the new Greece workout in the IMF's
ability to project their plan upon the
German people we've seen Paul deguire
LLC in leuven we've seen Charles why
plots in Geneva beg beg beg for a
restructuring exactly as the IMF
proposes what is taking so long what do
you need to get a proper debt workout
for the people of Greece well first of
all you have to realize that at the end
of 2012 we already the major depth
operation basically reducing the debt
burden for Greece annual debt burden by
forty percent and now we're looking
ahead what more needs to be done we can
take different measures some in the
short-term some at the end of the
program we're designing and discussing
those now and hopefully next Tuesday in
the next Eurogroup meeting will get that
deal that I think Greece needs and
deserves